right now I'm feeling new patterns being
molded into my mind what do I mean by
that well when I wake up in San
Francisco every single day it's pretty
much the same sort of routine activities
I wake up I get some hot water some hot
tea I do some exercise and I get right
onto my computer I start doing what I
want to get done that day
now when you wake up in Rome when you
wake up in a different part of the world
what ends up happening is your mind goes
whoa everything's brand new and when
everything is brand new the language the
scenery even the trees look different
that's when your brain starts Repat
earning its circuitry to be like whoa
new experience you can literally feel
yourself in awe and so go and travel go
and experience more places in the world
why are some new sort of electrical
signaling up here that will repattern
the way that you think about the world
and increase your awareness and your
your your heart your heart sensitivity
to other cultures and other places and
better understanding that we are one
that we are just one loving group of
advanced chimpanzees on this rock
orbiting the star let's work together
much love everyone